[Music]
you all right back there
it's a bumpy this this is nothing could
whip you around again
show you the old loop-de-loop
every family is weird but trust me
mine is the weirdest my dad
is bigfoot what's the next step clothing
line
sneaker endorsement video game deal yes
the bigfoot you wouldn't know it but
i'm a bigfoot too wow
extract oil puts nature first clean oil
by
extract clean oil you've got to be
kidding me
with your fame and influence you can
help stop extract before it's too late
you just got home you can't leave again
what's the point of fame if i don't use
it to make the world a better place
[Music]
why did extract need armed guards if
they've got nothing to hide
breaking news bigfoot has gone missing
what he needs our help
oh boy here we go again
hey guys buckle up so much for no
environmental impact
mom dad
hang on
let's finish this thing together
we're making pancakes hit me
oh shoot trapper don't thank me for your
lousy catch
[Music]
are you ready this is
come get some of this
who wants a selfie tentacular
i've got your whole life story tattooed
on my body
yeah in a long history of monster
wrestling there has never been a
champion quite like kentucky
fans around the world are asking is
there a challenger out there with the
hunger
the drive the discipline to become the
next
champion
what all right i think that's enough for
today
steve might not look like much but there
is a champion monster inside of him
did he eat thank you
that felt great
we seriously need to work on strength
and endurance fortunately i know just
the thing
what yeah that's going to be a hard no
for me
[Music]
oh do it again
[Music]
you got it oh boy oh this is my
nightmare
[Music]
katie used to be my little buddy go on
nature hikes
skip rocks
are you excited for cam don't make me go
we used to be so connected hey dad
smile you know you could experience
things a whole lot better without that
camera that this is how i experience
things
yes tomorrow i'm finally leaving for
college but in the meantime i made you
guys this goodbye video you know what
this is our last night together
how about we make 10 seconds family eye
contact starting put your phone down
now no you're allowed to blink it's just
eye contact oh finally no screens at the
table
linda why are you kicking me i don't
understand i'm just gonna look i'll
watch it dad it's too late
look i want to watch it uh
dad this is exactly why i'm excited to
leave tomorrow katie
i know you can fix this
why do you need all that to take me to
the airport i canceled your plane ticket
to college
we are gonna drive you to school on a
cross-country road trip as a family
behold and now i present freaking rick
mitchell to kiss me
dang it kitty dang it katie hey dad can
you check the trunk yeah sure
dang it katie hey kids there's supposed
to be some great ice around here just a
second
we hear a pound about to drop our
biggest invention yet
meet the helper bot we promise you they
will never
ever turn evil mom
what is that
greetings humans
technology rising up sayonara
robots roaming the streets what is this
strange creature
dog pig dog pig dog loaf of bread the
beaches have always been weird
no time to wash your hands don't worry i
never do that's what makes us great
that's my girl and we just might be
weird enough
to save the world all right hands in
oh oh he licked my tongue
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
focus me some shell
i gotcha
[Applause]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
my whole life i trained to become a
guardian of the dragon gem
but this world has changed
[Music]
and its people are divided
now to restore peace i must find
the last dragon
my name is raya
[Music]
ah in days of yore
there were two warriors i
kill for a spicy tuna roll right about
now get yourself a little something the
brothers
grew apart and a new age began in the
middle
edge dad uncle ted coming for christmas
this year
sweetie sometimes you just grow apart
diamond's all in my ring claire go watch
gold chain player
you can't solve everything with money
but you can you haven't changed at all
you're still a big baby
suck it ted you suck out of my face
excuse me
i hate to interrupt i mean it's a
riveting conversation but why don't you
suck it
she can talk a lot i'm in the family
business
and now you work for me boomers
baby corp developed a new formula that
can turn a grown-up back into a baby for
48 hours
you want me to be a baby again
[Music]
yep there's the awkward stage ew
baby corp will offer a full memory wipe
following this experience
what's the crisis an evil genius is
teaching kids
to be very bad bad babies welcome to the
baby
evolution we're gonna need a disguise to
go undercover
what have you done to me no really going
sailing
oh no
[Music]
thanks for always having my back you're
my brother we always stick together
because that's what families do
need to hurry before the formula wears
off
what the [ __ ] aren't you a cutie in that
little karate outfit
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh i'm
sure this isn't something money
can't solve superheroes
stand watch when danger closes in and
save those
in need but they have one thing in
common
they never show up in the real world
until ulysses
every superhero comes to us with a
purpose
we don't always see it at first
because we don't always know where to
look
flora what is this
i am ulysses born a new
holy unanticipated occurrences
did you type this
he's a superhero but
do you have any enemies i'm here about
the squirrel
danger lurks everywhere
is he he's flying
[Music]
there was a change in the air
what now come on
people look to the skies for someone to
save them
so the universe sent us
[Music]
ulysses
can you talk okay that's not really
talking but still
[Music]
after a lifetime of being the world's
most famous enemies
you can't
[Music]
in the big city
this hotel has been host to four
presidents three popes two kings
and we're about to host the wedding of
the century do you think you're
qualified to take on this position i
shine under pressure like a diamond
or rihanna one other thing
we have a mouse problem with the what
now i'll catch it sir
everybody gonna
oh wow this is so detailed
we could hire an exterminator or we can
leverage
millions of years of predatory evolution
[Applause]
[Music]
if a picture of this mouse tweet it up
to insta book face or tiki talk
we will be ruined no sir that's not
gonna happen
that rodent is toast
i will not let this hotel be ruined by a
cat in a mouth
he's dying on us
i think i might have just pulled this
[Music]
off
[Music]
ugh
we're back hey where you going i thought
we were going fishing
you're welcome
[Music]
a sequel how original
what are you doing here in somerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name is is creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate that has no fault lines
no fracking no loud music even is
shaking on a daily
come to the basis table now
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room killer
replica
a replica of what a ghost trap
[Music]
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the rub love's
life
wait a minute
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it faith
[Music]
call it lock
call it karma
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
get up here you big lump no one must
know there are dragons in the battle
fire drake stay out of trouble what was
that
humans i've always told you they're the
worst what will they do when they find
them
the rim of heaven huh a paradise
for dragons we could go there and lead
everyone to safety how are you planning
to get that
i've got wings haven't inspired
by cornelia funka's best-selling book so
genius
where do we start
hi you're him
yeah climb aboard dragon
[Music]
my pants yes tell them who you
are likes golf and easy dragons
i just saw a juicy silver dragon
hunger for a silver dragon let's get out
of here
look at us both roaring
many have searched but no one has found
the rim of heaven who's hungry now's not
the time for refreshments i'm trying to
be mystical
it was an arranged marriage you are much
more than you think you are
follow your heart and the truth will
come to you ready
ready join a gang of unlikely friends
[Music]
yep
[Music]
coming soon
[Music]
so what are you doing out here
there is a legend in the jungles of the
amazon
of a tree that heals all it could change
the world
but if it gets into the wrong hands it
could awaken
a great evil i believe that the legend
is
real and i'm gonna find it what you want
when i do just imagine the lives that
could be saved
i've been looking for this tree longer
than anybody
i've tracked a legend to every village
every island nothing
you're searching for something it can't
be found
but you've never had the key
let's do something that's safe let's go
see some elephants there are no
elephants in the amazon and i don't even
like elephants lady everybody likes
elephants
know this about the jungle everything
that you see
wants to kill you and can
careful they could smell fear i am not
afraid
oh my gosh who brings a submarine to the
amazon
[Music]
hold on come on i got it i don't got it
no no
no no no no no just leave me alone that
was a disaster it didn't go the way i
planned
[Music]
is anyone hungry yes starving i'm on it
i'm just going to wait until we get home
where the food isn't decomposing
well la dee da i didn't realize i was
with a bunch of sophisticates
families can come in all shapes and
sizes that's why i also feature having
some two-legged children
join them roll it imagine me and our
future children
frolicking this is fun i'm speeding up a
little
i'm speeding up quite a bit
i think he's getting the hang of it
tommy no those are mr mcgregors
i swear if it wasn't for me peter just
leave my tomatoes alone you have
everything else honestly my kids will be
so much better behaved go easy on him
as soon as they have a baby we're done
for
maybe we're better off without them
don't stare at the scenery rushing by
look at a fixed point on horizon and
just lock your eyes onto that
i love this place what's for lunch
there's a magical place with the ripest
radishes
the sweetest corn it's called the
farmer's market
and if you want an overpriced gift that
will never be used they show lavender
scented bath bombs
this sounds a bit dodgy i would never
put you in danger
i promise okay i can't promise we're
gonna go and rob this place you know
you're out
we're in run no
let them go my family's in trouble and
i'm gonna get them back
the other rabbits were taken and the pig
and the hedgehog
and the badger
let's go get the others why are you even
helping me
that's what a dad
[Applause]
[Music]
oh doesn't cottontail just discovered
sugar we had a good
run i'm gonna live forever
tell you this holiday season
we're thankful for the pets whose love
got us through the year
but next year get ready to love
even bigger
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
erica you haven't ever wished a family
would adopt you
have you nope
anybody who choose me would be pretty
unusual
we'll take this one for the first time
in my life i'm being made to do
something i don't want to do
now then let's you and i get a few
things straight
my name is bella yaga i'm a witch
great you agree that you'll teach me
magic
and i agree to help you out if you work
really hard
i shall do anything to hurt you
i love potion for the boy next door all
of these are pretty useless to me
the spell i believe you're looking for
is somewhere towards the back
hang on you actually talk of course i do
just not very often
in this household there's one rule
that's crucial
you must on no account for any reason
ever dare disturb the man drake don't be
rude
a hole left by a witch
i'll be learning magic well so i was
told can't wait to start
[Music]
i love my life i love you so much gary
i'll never forget the day we met
[Music]
hello little snail what's your name
scary huh do you want to be friends
me too gary
i'm home gary gare bear
gary gary have you seen gary
nope nope gary's been snail mapped
this summer the search begins friends
don't let friends go on dangerous quests
[Music]
with all new faces
hello call me sage good night i'm made
out of sage and i am a sage
so it works out pretty well i'm patrick
my name means
toaster in celtic pretty sure it doesn't
the most amazing places
the lost city of atlantic city boy i
hope we don't lose focus
look i wouldn't worry about us losing
ice cream
and a hero let it ride patrick
you can bet on put it on l
patrick that's not an l that's a seven
seven starts with an l
that's weird the spongebob movie
sponge on the run this
oh i love your sense of irony patrick
thank you
i love my sense of ironing too
remember what we talked about i don't
want to get a call from this new school
telling us that you've developed some
sort of chicken expanding rain
sorry about that
welcome to cranston academy look at this
place
from the creators of the nut job 2 and
escape from planet earth
i'd like to introduce you to danny
dawkins
thanks a lot genius danny dawkins is
about to discover
another world well that was monumental
who are you i guess you can call me
mothman
what kind of alien language is that
there are monsters everywhere is getting
bigger that means bigger monsters can
come out
how much bigger can they get
oh get ready to fight the monsters
save the school if anyone can stop these
things it's the smartest kids in the
world
you okay i admit that plan wasn't fully
thought out
featuring the voices of jamie bell and
ruby rose
let's do
go this go
monster zone you
didn't see nothing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]